[Musik]
in Buchen in Baden-Würtenberg gibt's im
Bahnhof diese neue Treppe dummerweise
ist sie seit Juli gesperrt beim Umbau
des Bahnhofs hat die Deutsche Bahn nicht
beachtet dass durch den Bud der Treppe
ein öffentlicher Weg durch den Bahnhof
entsteht da der Weg die Gleise kreuzt
muss der gesicherte Übergang jetzt
zusätzlich mit Andreas kreuzen und extra
Leuchten ausgestattet werden so
verlangen es die Vorschriften
mir sterben noch an an an der
vorschriftte da gehen mir Ei weil für
jedes Ding brauchen wirre Vorschrift
Gesetz irgendwas brauchen wir und das
das finde ich nicht richtig wenn doch
alles sicher ist warum muss man dan
nachrü also ist ja dann wieder unnötig
Geld da
verschwendet 2019 beginnt die Bahn mit
dem barrierefreien Umbau des Bahnhofs in
Buchen im Odenwald insgesamt 1,7
Millionen Euro werden dafür für fällig
in Absprache mit der Stadt wird am
Bahnsteig 2 diese Treppe gebaut um
besser zur Stadthalle zu kommen was
niemand bemerkt dadurch ändert sich der
Status des Übergangs über die Gleise
früher konnten nur Bahnreisende den
Übergang nutzen um zum Bahnsteig 2 zu
kommen mit der Treppe kann jetzt aber
jeder den Weg nutzen daher muss der
gesicherte Bahnübergang zusätzlich mit
Andreaskreuzen ausgestattet werden so
verlangt es die Eisenbahnbau und
Betriebsordnung bis dahin bleibt die
Treppe
zu wir stehen da fassungslos vor dieser
Sperrung wir haben funktionierende
Treppe die ist kein Sicherheitsrisiko
wir haben eine
fußgängerschranke es kann hier gar
nichts passieren bei der Deutschen Bahn
bedauert man dass die Menschen in Buchen
den neuen Weg nicht nutzen dürfen und
weiter heißt es schriftlich dennoch war
es gut und richtig die Treppe zu bauen
auch wenn die Sperrung etwas unglücklich
wirkt für viele Menschen ist die
treppensperrung eher ein schlechter
Treppenwitz ich kann doch eine Treppe
hochgehen und wenn der der überg also
ich brauche kein Andreaskreuz ich
brauche keine ampelanlager oder sonst
was ich brauch das nicht noch ein Kreuz
noch ein Kreuz und noch B anders kostet
alles ein Haufen Geld ich se es nicht
ein alles Steuergeld die Treppe bleibt
noch monatelang gesperrt erst 2024 soll
der Bahnübergang umgebaut werden wenn
nicht wieder eine neue Vorschrift alles
über den Haufen wirft